[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le parapente est vraiment un outil
formidable
il permet de prendre de la hauteur et de
découvrir notre magnifique planète
vu du ciel avec à chaque fois des
paysages à couper le souffle
à deux pas d'ici dans les alpes il est
possible de survoler des normes glaciers
comme le glacier blanc dans le massif
des écrins où la mer de glace à chamonix
d'ailleurs la dernière fois que nous
étions dans le petit train qui monte à
la mer de glace nous avions sympathisé
avec un homme assez âgé qui n'était plus
monté depuis une vingtaine d'années une
fois arrivés en haut il marque un temps
d'arrêt et nous demandent étonné mais où
est-ce qu'elle est passée il parlait de
la mer de glace celle ci on pouvait
l'admirer
dès l'arrivée du train à son époque
aujourd'hui il faut descendre un moment
avant de pouvoir y accéder
les alpes fondent les glaciers fondent
en 40 ans ils ont perdu en moyenne un
quart de leur superficie
certains prédisent même leur disparition
totale d'ici 2100 imaginez le mont blanc
n'aura de blanc plus que le nom depuis
1900 la température dans les alpes a
augmenté de 2 degrés soit deux fois plus
vite que la moyenne mondiale
c'est l'un des territoires les plus
sensibles au réchauffement climatique
et l'on s'en rend bien compte lorsqu'on
est sur balles un exemple spectaculaire
et le cratère de faire paître en suisse
où le glacier s'effondre sur lui même le
torrent a grossi et creusé un
gigantesque trou lors des récentes
canicule qui seront à l'avenir plus
forte et plus fréquentes avec le
réchauffement
l'urgence climatique est bien là et si
nous n'arrivons pas rapidement à réduire
nos émissions de gaz à effet de serre
les ags continuant de fond' mais avec
elle tous les territoires seront
impactés en france et dans le monde
certaines zones ne seront par exemple
plus du tout habitable à cause de
l'augmentation des événements extrêmes
comme les inondations les cyclones ou
les sécheresses
actuellement une personne des ménages
chaque seconde
pour des raisons climatiques on connaît
bien les tensions engendrées par les
phénomènes migratoires comme ce que nous
avons vu actuellement en europe
en comparaison les réfugiés climatiques
sont cent fois plus nombreux ce qui
pourrait entraîner des déstabilisations
géopolitique majeur et menacer la paix
dans le monde
les crises migratoires ne sont qu'un des
exemples des effets néfastes du
réchauffement climatique et les en a
bien d'autres
les disparitions massives d'espèces les
pertes de biodiversité la dégradation
des sols avec des effets sur
l'agriculture et sur l'alimentation
alors comment traiter ce problème
la réponse n'est bien sûr pas évidente
ce qui est sûr c'est qu'elle doit l'être
à l'échelle mondiale cette carte montre
les émissions de co2 instantanée et la
concentration de co2 instantanée dans
l'atmosphère on voit bien que les gaz à
effet de serre n'ont pas de frontières
traiter ce problème du réchauffement
climatique à l'échelle mondiale c'est un
peu le but des cop ces grandes
conférences des parties pour trouver des
accords entre tous les pays du monde
pour limiter leurs gaz à effet de serre
et ainsi limiter le réchauffement global
des températures en dessous de deux
degrés comme ce que préconise la corde
paris c'est ce que nous essayons de
faire lorsque j'ai travaillé à l'équipe
que 21 le problème de toutes ces grandes
réunions onusiennes et qui est difficile
de prendre des actions concrètes
rapidement pour faire face à l'urgence
climatique parce qu'il ya un blocage
récurrent entre le les pays du nord et
les pays du sud le problème aussi dans
le consensus qu'on a trouvé entre tous
est payé on voit bien sur cette nouvelle
carte qui montre les émissions cumulées
de co2 depuis les années 1750 jusqu'en
2014 on voit bien le clivage entre les
pays du nord et les pays riches
en effet les pays du nord ont profité de
leur révolution industrielle pour se
développer et nous permet d'avoir les
conditions de confort incroyable que
nous connaissons aujourd'hui
pour cela nous avons dû émettre beaucoup
de gaz à effet de serre un moment où
personne ne parlait de changement
climatique et on pensait encore que
l'homme ne pouvait pas impacter les
équilibres de notre planète par ses
activités en revanche beaucoup de pays
notamment en afrique
n'ont pas encore entamé cette et centres
industriels liés au développement humain
il revendique donc ce droit à émettre
des gaz à effet de serre pour se
développer
l'une des premières étapes de ce
développement humain et l'accès à une
énergie moderne et propre notamment
l'accès à l'électricité
en effet imaginez vous vivre sans
électricité sans électricité impossible
de conserver des aliments des vaccins
impossible aussi d'utiliser toutes les
machines qui nous entourent et qui nous
facilitent la vie que ce soit pour
pomper de l'eau pour sa forme et pour
communiquer pour fabriquer ou pour
réparer des biens l'électricité est
devenu indispensable au développement
alors bien sûr des solutions existent
pour l'électricité de façon décarbonés
dans ces zones isolées cette petite
lampe solaire permet par exemple de
s'éclairer et de recharger un téléphone
portable ou d'autres petits appareils
comme des radios d'autre solution plus
puissante vont permettre de satisfaire
des besoins électriques en électricité
plus importants comme ceux d'un village
entier le problème de toutes ces
solutions et qu'elles sont encore
difficilement accessible pour la plupart
des habitants sans axel est restée est
aujourd'hui encore plus d'un milliard de
personnes n'ont toujours pas accès
principalement dans beaucoup de zones
rurales en afrique subsaharienne
comme on le voit sur cette photographie
donné l'une des spécificités du
continent africain et que c'est le seul
continent où ce nombre de personnes sans
accès à l'électricité va augmenter dans
les prochaines décennies
cela est notamment dû à une croissance
démographique importante sur un
continent où plus de la moitié de la
population habitera d'ici 2000 sont les
le développement humain et l'essor
industriel de tous ses habitants
représente un énorme potentiel
d'émissions de gaz à effet de serre si
les schémas développement suivi sont les
mêmes que ceux que nous avons suivi par
le passé 1 électricité de façon
renouvelables partout dans le monde et
de façon décarbonée c'est une des
possibilités offertes par une multitude
d'outils innovants qui ont été créés
grâce aux révolutions industrielles ou
précédentes révolutions industrielles
tous ces outils vont nous permettre
d'impacter les deux grands volets des
actions liées au changement climatique
que sont l'adaptation et l'atténuation
commençons par l'adaptation l'accès à
l'électricité va permettre aux habitants
de s'adapter aux effets du réchauffement
climatique tout en leur permettant
d'améliorer leurs conditions de vie on
parlait tout à l'heure du survol des
glaciers dans les alpes savez vous qu'il
est aussi possible de survoler des
glaciers en afrique
nous sommes actuellement en train de
préparer une expédition en tanzanie pour
décoller du toit de l'afrique
le mont kilimandjaro grâce au
réchauffement on aura même plus besoin
d'emporter des piolets ou des crampons
dans nos valises les glaciers du
kilimandjaro ont presque disparu en une
centaine d'années c'est un très bon
exemple du stress écologique que subit
le continent africain
ce château d'eau de l'afrique fournissez
des ressources en eau à des milliers
d'habitants aux alentours avec
s'affrontent les habitants subissent des
sécheresses à importantes et sont
obligés de quitter leurs villages pour
s'adapter différents projets le voyou
voit le jour pour amener des pompes
alimentées par des panneaux solaires
pour puiser l'eau à quelques dizaines de
mètres de profondeur l'accès y est
restée va donc permettre à ses habitants
de s'adapter aux effets néfastes du
réchauffement climatique en continuant
de vivre dans leur village et en
limitant ainsi les migrations pour
raisons climatiques
regardons maintenant le deuxième volet
des actions liées au changement
climatique
l'atténuation c'est à dire comment
réduire nos émissions de gaz à effet de
serre
actuellement la solution de facilité
pour amener l'électricité dans les zones
reculées
ces groupes électrogènes l'afrique en
apporte plus d'un million par an c'est
simple efficace et on est sûr d'avoir de
l'électricité temps qu'on a du carburant
par contre ça va polluer émettent
beaucoup de gaz à effet de serre et
contribuer ainsi au réchauffement
climatique l'enjeu est alors de créer de
nouvelles solutions pour amener les
tristes et renouvelables partout dans le
monde
ces solutions doivent être compétitive
en termes de coût par rapport aux
groupes électrogènes mais aussi en
termes de praticité tout en assurant de
même qualité de service
le défi est immense mais pas impossible
si on considère l'énorme potentiel du
continent africain en termes de
ressources renouvelables et les
nouvelles technologies
ces nouvelles technologies vont
permettre de créer de nouveaux modèles
de développement complètement
révolutionnaire c'est notamment le cas
pour le modèle d'électrification latéral
prenons l'exemple d'un village qui n'a
pas encore accès à l'électricité
pour l'illustrer au lieu d'être eefje
tout le monde tout de suite avec une
grande compagnie d'électricité on va y
aller progressivement en répondant aux
réels besoins des populations et en
créant de la valeur et de l'emploi
localement au début un entrepreneur va
se former un entrepreneur local va se
former et créer une petite entreprise
il va alors créer un tout petit réseau
électrique très simple composé
uniquement de quelques panneaux solaires
et quelques batteries et d'autres
composants
la simplicité du système et sa proximité
avec les habitants va lui permettre de
délivrer un service électrique fiable et
durable dans le temps au fur à mesure
que les usages se développent les
besoins en est restée vont augmenter
l'entrepreneur pas leur décidé d'ajouter
des panneaux solaires et des batteries
mais les habitants eux aussi peuvent
décider d'investir dans des panneaux
solaires et batteries
l'électricité ne sera alors plus
uniquement une source de dépense pour
ses habitants mais aussi une source de
revenus et c'est là où les nouvelles
technologies vont permettre de faciliter
la gestion de ses systèmes notamment
l'association des compteurs intelligents
avec la technologie bloc chaîne
vous avez forcément déjà entendu parler
de la blague chaîne c'est cette
technologie révolutionnaire qui est
derrière les crypto monnaie comme le pit
lane
ces évolutions depuis 2008 sont
fulgurantes et on arrive aujourd'hui à
tout un tas de possibilités incroyables
dans plein de domaines
c'est notamment le cas pour
l'électricité une block chaînes locales
dans notre exemple qui ne consomme
presque pas d'électricité va permettre
de gérer automatiquement et en toute
transparence les échanges d'électricité
et de monnaie dans des systèmes
complexes où tout le monde peut être
consommateur et au producteur à fur et à
mesure au fur et à mesure que le village
se développent les autres zones du
village vont accéder avec triste
il va ensuite être possible
d'interconnecter ces différentes zones
pour tirer profit de la complémentarité
entre les usages là encore il suffit de
relier ces différentes zones avec des
câbles électriques et ensuite tout est
géré automatiquement par la blague
chaîne grâce avec ses lectrices t des
petites industries ou des petits
commerces vont pouvoir développer des
centrales solaires plus importantes
voies aussi secret pour répondre à des
besoins plus importants en électricité
comme pour faire tourner des deux
grosses machines agricoles
on va voir alors tout un écosystème se
crée autour de cet axe elle est restée
en partant d'une approche bottom up
complètement différente des approches
top donne qui ont vu le la naissance de
nos grands réseaux électriques c'est
approche bottom up vont donner beaucoup
plus de pouvoir aux citoyens
on lui permettront d'être acteur dans la
gestion de son électricité et plus
uniquement spectateur ou consommateurs
elles vont aussi permettre la création
de réseaux électriques qui sont beaucoup
plus modulaire beaucoup plus flexible
capable d'intégrer une grande part
d'électricité renouvelable contrairement
à l'inertie des grands réseaux que nous
connaissons la blocs chaîne va être un
magnifique outil pour faciliter la
création et la gestion de ces grands
réseaux intelligents décentralisée elle
va aussi offrir deux possibilités
remarquables
la première est qu avec la belote
chaînes n'auront même plus besoin de
monnaie pour acheter attractif notre
électricité une famille en afrique qui
cultivent du manioc va par exemple
pouvoir directement échanger une partie
de sa récolte contre une quantité donnée
d es christ et à une autre famille qui
aurait installé un panneau solaire sur
le toit de sa maison
la deuxième possibilité remarquable
offert par les blocs chaînes concernées
dont que nous faisons à des associations
qui parmi vous a déjà réussi à savoir
comment l'argent qu'il avait donnée
était utilisée difficile non avec la
blogueuse chaîne vous allez pouvoir
directement recharger sur internet le
compteur intelligent d'une famille dans
un village électrifié en étant
totalement sûr que votre don servira
uniquement à couvrir les besoins
d'électricité de cette famille là blocs
chaîne dans le modèle d'électrification
latéral
ce n'est qu'un exemple des nombreuses
possibilités offertes par les nouvelles
technologies pour réduire nos émissions
de gaz à effet de serre contribuent à la
lutte contre le réchauffement climatique
tout en assurant le développement humain
en conclusion il ya une bonne et une
mauvaise nouvelle la mauvaise nouvelle
est que oui les effets du réchauffement
climatique sont bien là et vont
probablement s'amplifier dans les
prochaines années
cela va créer tout un tas de problèmes
auxquels l'humanité va devoir faire face
en s'adaptant et en faisant preuve
d'empathie envers les populations les
plus exposées
la bonne nouvelle est que nous pouvons
encore limiter ses effets du
réchauffement
car nous disposons déjà de tout un tas
d'outils révolutionnaire qui vous permet
de créer de nouveaux modèles de
développement plus juste plus durable et
plus respectueux de l'environnement
c'est le cas pour l'accès à est restée
comme nous l'avons vu mais c'est le cas
aussi pour plein d'autres domaines que
ce soit l'agriculture la santé ou
l'éducation
tous ces magnifiques des outils ont été
obtenus au prix d'une dégradation
massive de l'état de santé de notre
planète
alors à nous maintenant de les mobiliser
intelligemment pour lui redonner vie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]